do you know what Javier M's nickname was
when he was a kid his nickname was El
loo Mr madman you know why cuz he had a
temper he was angry he liked Sports he
liked all these other things he liked
football and then all of a sudden when
he's growing up he like what the hell is
going on to the country here so he gets
obsessed with capitalism Von misus Hayek
root to Surf them fully obsessed he was
a professor he had all these rants on TV
that he would do and then eventually he
runs for office and he becomes a
president and gets invited to the
institution the organization that he
criticized publicly Non-Stop World
economic forum and they're expecting him
to go on stage and give an angry rant so
CLA shop can say look at this man he's
not under control and he goes on stage
and gives a message so beautiful direct
based on stats data history silences
everybody as 23 minutes if you haven't
watched it I'm going to choose a couple
parts of what he gave the speech up we
have all the data here but he said a
couple things that I want to talk to
about in this video which is going to
make you very proud as a capitalist to
not let the State make you play defense
instead constantly play offense simply
based on a message that he gave so if
you get value out of this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get right into it so imagine in
the 1800s 95% of the world is living in
extreme poverty 1800 everybody's trying
to figure out what the hell are we going
to do to get 95% of the world to not be
controlled by the powerful government
leaders that are putting their thumb you
better do this or else and everybody's
poor and Afraid right just trying to
take care of their wife and kids and
then the Industrial Revolution starts
capitalism starts today pre- pandemic
less than 5% extreme poverty worldwide
due to capitalism this is one of the
things Javier mle talks about and he
continues while he's giving these stats
and was like what is this guy talking
about you can't give a message like this
and then he says this in front of
everybody he says countries that have
more freedom are 12 times richer than
those that are repressed the lowest
pertile in free countries is better off
than 90% of the population in depressed
countries meaning free market free
capital Z he continues poverty is 25
times lower and extreme poverty is 50
times lower and citizens in free
countries live 25% longer than citizens
in repressed countries so imagine to the
audience you're giving a speeches so if
you're giving a speech to an audience
like I remember being a financial
adviser I'm 21 years old working on
Morgan Stanley deal with a 22 years old
and I'm talking to an audience of 30 65
year olds and I get up on stage and I
say imagine if one day you have a
Ferrari nice car and you're traveling
all over the world and you live in this
big house and I see nobody from the
audience was interested in my message
and afterwards my guy comes up and he
says listen why are you selling this to
the these people are not interested in
your message and they looked at me funny
they're like they want a nice slow car
in a very small house with least amount
of cleaning to do they want the least
amount of stress this guy gets up in
front of the audience of world economic
forum and tells him you guys are all
full of is what he said he says
you're trying to control the world world
is better without you guys getting in
their way let them be free don't bother
free people stop trying to control
people because this is the solution to
being free and being healthier and
getting rid of poverty not some of the
nonsense ideas that you have he says it
to their faces in a commas tone not the
typical tone you have your melee in then
he continues cuz everybody says you know
all these companies going out of
business it's capitalism's fault he says
wrong it's impossible for there to be
Market market failures what does he mean
by this the market is not a mere graph
describing a curve of supply and demand
the market is a mechanism for social
cooperation where you voluntarily
exchange ownership rights therefore
based on this definition talking about a
market failure is an oxymoron there are
no market failures if transactions are
voluntary the only context in which
there can be market failure is if there
is coercion and the only one that is
able to coers generally is the state
which holds a monopoly on violence there
is only Monopoly with the government
getting involved and creating regulation
for all others he's trying to say there
is no such thing as market failure and
socialists and those who work for the
state who want to over-regulate
everything can't stand that message they
want all the blame to be on the
capitalist and then he continues to take
shots at the states and here's what he
says today states don't need to directly
control the means of production to
control every aspect of the lives of
individuals the states use tools such as
printing money debt subsidies
controlling the interest rate price
controls regulation to correct so-called
market failures does that remind you of
any country maybe the freest country in
the world at one point maybe the
greatest country in the world does that
remind you on what's going on in America
isn't this kind of affecting some people
right now these are all the mechanism
the state uses to destroy the economy
rather than getting out of the way and
last but not least he gives a direct
message to all the business people
around the world which I love here's
what he says do not be intimidated by
the political cast or by parasites who
live off of the state don't be
intimidated by the people that live off
of the state cuz they make you feel
guilty do not surrender to a political
class that only wants to stay in power
and retain its privileges they get to
live their life by pulling a card and
saying I'm a senator I'm a congressman
I'm a president I'm president's son wink
this is okay let me do this if you do
this I'll do this for your father I'll
do this with my father all this up he
says do not surrender to a political
class that only wants to stay in power
and retain its privileges it's like a
membership you have to a country club
you get to go on if you have that card
the political class doesn't want to give
up that membership they want to control
because a lot of weird benefits comes
with this card that they have such as
Insider information that I get to invest
into certain companies that you don't
get to do I won't go to jail but if you
do it you would go to jail that's called
political class you are social
benefactors what does it mean it's not
the government that makes the society a
better place you do by creating jobs you
do by starting a business that maybe
competes against the guy across the
street cuz your coffee is cheaper your
burger is cheaper your service is better
you are the social benefactor you make
the world a better place not the
government you are the heroes I've been
talking about the biggest problem in
America the last four years is the hero
making machine we have in America kids
have no clue what hero to look up to do
I look up to that person that's a guy
dressed like a girl do I look up to this
per who the hell do I look I don't know
who to look up to cuz we're confused no
job creators you work your ass off
you're a hero this is not easy it's very
very hard you work day and night doing
what you're doing capitalist for some of
you that are Executives working for a
company helping to grow you're working
on a Saturday late at night you're
putting up a plan together it's not easy
you are a hero to society you make sure
companies stay around to keep those jobs
for people that are making 50,000 a year
100,000 a year $150,000 a year and for
the customers that are buying the
product you are the hero not enough
people are recognizing in you he's
saying it very aligned message with what
Val Tim stands for because you make the
world go around and we salute you you
are the creators of the most
extraordinary period of prosperity we've
ever seen you let no one tell you that
your ambition is immoral oh you're too
ambitious why do you do this what else
do you need how much more money do you
need how many more car why do you care
it's none of your business buddy let me
live my life and go why are you making
me feel guilty about it don't let
anybody make you feel guilty about your
vision you pursue your vision that
matters to you and your family if you
make money it's because you offer a
better product at a better price thereby
contributing to General wellbeing go
make your money just make sure you're
doing it legally but go make your money
do not surrender to the advance of the
state the state is not the solution the
state is the problem itself you are the
true protagonist of this story and rest
assured that as from today Argentina is
your staunch and unconditional Ally you
know why I love this last night we're
having dinner at the house and we have
all our sea Executives so one of the
things we do is when it comes on to
hiring a SE Suite the last thing I like
to do is I want to meet your spouse I
want to meet your husband or your wife
and last night everyone's at the house
we have dinner our Executives brought
their spouses and this new seite
Executives that we're looking at hiring
is there with his wife and we're going
back and forth having the conversation
we're talking to one another and in the
middle of the conversation I asked so
what do you think about what we stand
for as a company what questions do you
have for me what challenges do you have
I would much rather know to see if this
is a fit or not and I said how do you
feel about the fact that you know we do
what we do politically and we're pretty
alloud about you know does that kind of
bother you no what about this this this
and then eventually the more and more we
opened up about what the company's
values and principles are conversation
led to the following so I think it's
important you know where I stand with
this what's that I said you know there
is many decisions you can make when you
make money one of the things you can do
is make your money and be cool and take
that money to go out there and benefit
from it enjoy peaceful life relax kick
back don't do anything else don't be too
rowdy cuz you're afraid if somebody's
going to watch you a little bit too much
with your money and you have less Target
less any of that stuff and who cares if
they're doing what they're doing at
schools who cares if they're trying to
confuse your kids as long as your kids
are going to be okay you're going to be
all right right I said a lot of people
take that position and why do they take
that position less controversy less
conflict more peaceful less being in a
tension mode maybe they won't get your
kids and confuse your kids but maybe
they'll get your grandkids and
definitely they're going to get your
great grandkids are you okay with that
and I said I'm not I'm simply not so
what is happening to the world today you
know what's happening to the world today
is people like Javier mle are being born
in times like this by the way prior to
year ago did you know who he was maybe
you're watch I had no clue who he was
you do now what happened what changed
because there's a conflict and the state
and the people who are you know these
powerful people the elites are trying to
control what you decisions you need to
make and all of a sudden he comes no hey
maybe the state you got to take the
vaccine all RFK comes and no we got to
argue this hey we got to go sometime no
like whoa I thought I was a bad person I
thought I was dumb I thought I was I'm
not I mean these guys are making me
realize what decisions I'm making I'm
not the only person that's going through
this and then eventually you have to
make a decision for yourself what part
of the camp are you going to be you're
going to be the camp that's going to be
the quiet timid one or you're going to
join the different camps to become more
and more and more powerful because the
reality of it is if you're watching this
as a business owner there are more and
more people out there that are willing
to defend you and give you respect and
love that you deserve for the hard work
you're putting in you're not alone
sometimes you feel like you're alone
you're not alone there's many of us and
we're finding each other it's the most
beautiful thing you know what I love
about our annual conference that we do
Vault conference we do this once a year
this last year we did it was down here
in Miami at the Diplomat Tom Brady was
there Mike Tyson was there you're in a
room with 200 other people you know how
everybody feels like-minded people value
Tim and pbd P get similar value similar
principles similar Vision similar kind
of ways that they want to build their
lives in one room this year we're doing
it at Palm Beach we're expecting 10,000
people to be at Palm Beach with us
phenomenal event we'll make the
announcements here very soon but I'm
sharing this with you because if you're
watching the saying I want to be around
more people like that go to places where
those people are and establish
relationships with them by the way if
you do want to attend the Vault
conference 2024 on Palm Beach text the
word Vault to 3103 41132 again text the
word Vault to
31034 11132 if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel and if you enjoyed this
video there's another video we did on
what happened to Argentina's economy and
what this guy proposed to change
everything about Argentina's economy if
you've never seen a click here to watch
it take care everybody bye- bye
bye-bye